have you ever tried nofap
eight years he's laughing
eight years what was voluntary selling
no fap
sema retention yeah
it was very difficult
and it produced a lot of problems and i
made a lot of bad decisions huh it
caused problems for you yeah eight years
ago
no no no nothing at all no excuse me
okay well there was there were some
points here and there but the whole time
i became very religious um this was
around 2004 i had been working on cruise
ships for a few years
and that's pretty much like living in a
vegas hotel
um no place for a 19 year old
so at 24 i was exhausted and i realized
that i had not matured one bit
i needed to go home and grow up
so
i went home
i grew up i quit drinking i quit smoking
i quit messing with girls
i got very religious
and went all in like i always do with
everything
i'm not going to do it if it's halfway
did you realize i don't know eight years
is a long time but at some point did you
realize that when when you were not
releasing you were more productive
because you're probably thinking your
brain is thinking like okay look i'm not
releasing something's wrong i need to
release so i need to do more things to
impress or whatever i've heard this
before um i've heard that there's some
eastern disciplines that have this
and i've heard in the modern rp era some
guys are promoting this
i'm not going to knock it
because i feel that anything you can do
to promote self-control is going to help
you reach your goal period
however
i can't say that in my own personal
experience
that not
how do you say releasing my seed into
the wild
has
resulted directly in more production
i would say that
focus produces production
more than anything
and if you're using the no fab thing to
help you stay focused fine
but i don't see that as a direct
connection in my own experience it may
work for other people but in my own
experience when i started meditating
when i eliminated the things out of my
life that were wasting my time and not
helping me toward my goal
when i eliminated the people that were
in my life that were not helping me to
my goal and i started focusing on that
singular goal that's what produced more
of my my progress than
you know just um
not coming yeah exactly i think because
i think a man should come regularly i
mean i subscribe to the whole thing if a
woman you know uh i i apologize if this
gets
blocked but
i've heard this statement before
keep your man's balls empty and his
belly full and you'll never have to
worry about him coming home
but i think there's coming home
there's something i said in the uk a lot
which is um you know
don't die from yash because guys are out
here doing certain things for
um just to get goals right and a lot of
times that can be
um detrimental to
what they want from one and one out of
life in terms of success uh you know
family and all those things right so i
think that's why
the there's there can be a positive to
the whole nofap thing because it can
focus you if you're not trying to deal
with um that side of
life in terms of women and things like
that but i don't think it's even i mean
everything kind of comes down to women
really in the end for men because that's
why we do everything subconsciously
but i wouldn't say i personally and i'm
sure many others did it because they
want to get laid but it's just like in
the back of your head like i imagine i'm
sure you work out like you work out
imagine you know
do more of those before the gym you're
probably not going to be as energetic as
yeah
someone in the chat said you can have
prostate problems if you don't ejaculate
yeah i'm not saying dude all the time
that's going to be the hardest thing
ever
but to go back to your original question
i
personally think that society
would be a little bit worse if
all of
the men's sexual needs were met because
of women and i think that
right now
half of the men's needs aren't met and
women are still crazy if women knew that
this girl this girl this girl this girl
this girl is sleeping with the man that
they want oh they would go berserk
because all the men's needs are being
met by
umpteen girls and actually
oh it would be crazy so oh we would we
would kill each other yeah
it'd be great for men they would love it
to
have their needs met but it would be
substantially worse because women would
now know that
now we know there's multiple women for
every single guy just imagine if every
guy when they were born they're like
here's a list of five women you will
have throughout your whole life that you
can keep well and the problem is then it
would be a smaller percentage of men
having
having all the women if sexuality was
just untapped it wouldn't be like every
guy got a girl it'd be a growing like
the number of virgins would male virgins
would get higher
and i guess that's like a really like
i've heard rollo talk about this where
that's a really big problem in societies
where if you have a large amount of
basically guys with no girls they get
angry
and then
i don't know bad stuff like bad stuff
happens i don't know what well it's kind
of like today right yeah yeah and today
we have
a group of men
who
are
dealing with hypersexual women
that are absolutely fine with having
multiple partners so that one guy can
have six or seven women at once
and the other
five or six men
that should have a pair are just sitting
there
trying to not fat
interesting
so um i have a question for the men and
your
experience who do you know know more men
that have been abused by women or women
that have been abused by men just
anecdotally no data
just go around uh if you mean by abuse
you mean like being hit or yeah
physically let's just let's start
physically i guess i know more men have
been hit by women
um more men that have been hit by women
i don't know what the statistics are but
in my own life
i have been hit by a woman
attacked had to call the police
not that i couldn't fight back
but i chose to call the police instead
of do what i know my body could do to
preserve the situation
and prevent any arrests so i can say
first hand in my own experience
that in my life
there have been more women attacking men
what was um did it come out of nowhere
no i saw it coming i was prepared
okay she had been out all night drinking
with her friends on a girl's night out i
was home with a baby
yeah the baby didn't want to go to sleep
because she just likes to stay up and
kick it with me and listen to music
four in the morning she shows up
i've um
i've known more women
but i've noticed that a lot of them
might be lying also lived in sweden for
five years and they kind of just
to themselves abuse for example is just
some guy looking at them you know
and in sweden like they say like it's
it's like the capital of europe
and the reason why excuse me sorry the
reason why is because apparently
that's not me saying